- Speaking of connection though,
is it 15 years that you just
celebrated with your wife?
- 15 years.
- Congratulations.
(audience cheers)
But y'all have been
together for over 20, right?
- [J.B.] Been together 20,
yeah. Been together 20.
And now 15 years.
- [Kelly] Look at that beautiful smile.
- My girlfriend.
- Oh, I love that.
- You know what she loves?
I don't know if I can even clear this,
but she loves when I seen Bobby
Brown "Girlfriend" to her.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- She loves it.
♪ I need a girlfriend ♪
- That's your sexy time. Okay.
Aye.
- You gotta have, see,
I think it's like this.
You got to, even when you married,
you have to have a
girlfriend-boyfriend relationship with
your companion because it just
keeps it fresh all the time.
You're always courting somebody,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- And that's what, we have
fun. We really have fun.
And you know, I call her my sunshine.
That's my boo. That's my boo. My boo.
- I love that. Your sunshine.
So wait, you always say
that she's your rock.
So what's something that
you think you wouldn't
have gotten through without her?
- Oh man, this whole industry.
This, you know, you know how it is.
It's huge. It's a lot that goes into this.
And I think, you know, having support
of someone is the number
one thing you need
in this business.
- Absolutely.
- [J.B.] Is having a
companion who's supportive.